it's pride month and rebel wilson is
celebrating in a big way introducing the
world to her girlfriend ramona aguruma
yes i love this so rebel went public
with their relationship by sharing a
sweet snap on instagram writing in the
caption i thought i was searching for a
disney prince but maybe what i really
needed all this time was a disney
princess hashtag love is love i love
that and a source tells our friends at
entertainment tonight they are very
happy together and their friends are so
supportive of their relationship and
thrilled for them
yes now last month rebel did confirm
that she was dating someone special
during an appearance on the up podcast
while also revealing how they met
are you seeing anyone now what's the
what's going on in your love life yeah
so now happily in a relationship
where did you meet your current partner
uh set up it was a friend set up uh
because i was i i still was on and off
on that uh ryan
but um yeah no this was a friend set up
and he'd known both of us
um for like at least five years each and
was like yeah i think you two would hit
it off and then we did those are the
best type of meetings that's what
everyone wants but also
it's nice what you said just now like
you know he knew they knew us both for
five years yeah you know like it was a
trusted
you know uh referral so to speak yeah
and i think jared that escalates things
quicker because from a trusted source so
then you're like okay yeah okay i can i
can trust this this person that they're
a legit they are who they say they are
which is something on the apps you don't
really know
i love this visario saying so happy for
rebel and for coming out which is really
exciting
i love this going through friend who
knows of this person so apparently she's
a jewelry designer they were seen uh as
far back as january of this year so it's
looking good
it's looking good you gotta love a good
you know setup from a friend they always
be knowing and then also it's like
they're kind of like holding the whole
situation together in a certain way and
then you can like you have someone to
blame
[Laughter]
oh do you have personal experience with
this i don't really have a whole lot of
friends i trust when it comes to their
opinions about who i should date so i
don't think i've ever been set up by a
friend is that weird
omg what kind of friends you got girl
i don't know
i let her out i know i'm just i'm so
excited
for rebel i feel like she's gone through
this huge transformation uh physically
emotionally you know relationship wise
so this just feels like such a new
beginning and honestly an honest
beginning for her you know just seeing
so um her really owning who she truly is
and and she seems happier than ever she
really does
oh i don't know she made me want to
switch teams all right
good to know good to know that what it
was okay